الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اتهمت وكاله الطاقه النوويه الاوكرانيه
روسيا بقصف محطه النوويه وقالت الوكاله
النفنتي عشره ضرب على الاقل سجلت في موقع
المحطه روسيا تعرض العالم باسره للخطر
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه
سنهويه
نقل الكهرباء اليها وتعمل متحدث باسم
الوزاره
اوكرانيا بما سماها استفزازات هدفوها
احداثها كارثه النوويه
لا يتوقف نظام كيف عن الاستفزازات الهادفه
لخلق تحديد بوقوع كارثه في محطه
النوويه خلال اليوم الماضي اطلقت مدفعيه
القوات الاوكرانيه 11 قذيفه مدفعيه من
العيار الثقيل على المحطه كما قصفتها
مرتين اليوم في فتره الصباح تم اطلاقه
اثنتي عشره قذيفه مدفعيه انفجرت حول وحدات
الطاقه بعد ذلك اطلقت قديفتان اصابتا خط
الكهرباء الذي يغذي المحطه قوتنا ردت
بتدمير موقع اطلاق نيران العدو في مستوطنه
مارجانيز بمقاطعه ديني بروستد الوضع
الاشعاعي في المحطه ما زال طبيعيه سيتم
توضيحه عواقب الاضرار الناجمه عن القسم
بعد فحص المحطه من قبل خبراء وكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه ومؤسسات روز
تمت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كيف بمواصله
الاستفزازات بهدف خلقي تهديدا بوقوع كارثه
في محطه زبرجيا للطاقه النوويه وكان
مستشار مدير مؤسسه الطاقه النوويه الروسيه
رناتشا قد قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه شنت
قسطا ادفعليا على محطه ايزابيروجين
القصف قال مستودعا لتخزين الوقود النووي
المستعمل حديثا وحوضا مياه لتبريد
المفاعلات النوويه مشيرا الى وجود خطا
الاستهدافات جديده للمحطه من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني